Over 40 years ago,
US President Richard Nixon declared drug abuse public enemy number one,
starting an unprecedented global campaign.
We're the war on drugs today.
The numbers are in the war on drugs is a huge failure with devastating,
unintended consequences.
It led to mass incarceration in the u s to corruption,
political destabilization and violence in Latin America and Asia and Africa to
systemic human rights abuses across the world.
It negatively affected the lives of millions of people.
All of this,
while we waste billions of dollars every year only to create and feel powerful
drug cartels,
while the goal of the war on drugs that seems less achievable than ever a world
without drugs,
how could this happen?
The coolest strategy of the war on drugs is no drugs,
no problems.
So almost all of the efforts in the last few decades have been focused on
eradicating the supply of drugs and incarcerating drug traffickers.
But this ignores the most fundamental of market forces,
supply and demand.
If you reduce the supply of anything without reducing the demand,
first it's price goes up.
This might lower sounds for many products,
lip,
not for drugs.
The drugs market is not price sensitive,
drugs will be consumed no matter what they cost.
So the effect is to encourage production of more drugs and recruitment of more
traffickers which increases availability.
This is also known as the balloon effect.
Even if drug production or a major supply route is destroyed,
the supply for the end user is not reduced.
The perfect example of this is crystal meth.
The U s government tried to stop his production by strictly regulating the sound
of chemicals used to manufacture the drug.
This forced a big math producers out of business,
but the unintended consequences with thousands of small scale operations,
it started all over the country,
mostly in small towns and rural communities using chemicals that weren't
regulated.
In response to this,
some US states wanted to reduce the supply of homegrown math by regulating even
more chemicals,
which reduced the small scale mass production drastically.
But the supply of math still stayed the same.
Mexican drug cartels immediately took over and opened big production operations.
Their math was even better than it was before and they had loads of experience
in smuggling.
So all these efforts made math production more professional.
The drug more potent while supplying wasn't reduced at all.
You can't win this war on the supply side.
Not only are drugs widely available,
demand unbroken and some drugs pure than in the past with a budget of around $30
billion.
The US Drug Enforcement Agency has an efficiency rate of less than 1% when it
comes to stopping the flow of drugs into the u s and inside the u s for many
miners around the world,
it's as easy to get illegal drugs as alcohol,
but it doesn't stop here.
Prohibition may prevent a certain amount of people from taking drugs,
but in the process it causes huge damage to society as a whole.
Many of the problems we associated with drug use are actually caused by the war
against them.
For example,
prohibition makes drug stronger.
The more potent drugs you can store and as little space as possible,
the more profit you'll make.
It was the same during alcohol prohibition,
which led to an increased consumption of strong liquor over bear.
The prohibition of drugs also lead to more violence and murders around the
world.
Gangs and cartels have no access to the legal system to settle disputes,
so they use violence.
This led to an ever increasing spiral of brutality.
According to some estimates,
the homicide rate in the US is 25 to 75% higher because of the war on drugs and
in Mexico,
the country on the front line,
an estimated 164,000 have been murdered between 2007 and 2014 more people than
in the war zones of Afghanistan and Iraq in the same period combined.
But where the war on drugs might do the most damage to society is the
incarceration of nonviolent drug offenders.
For example,
the United States,
one of the driving forces of the war on drugs has 5% of the world's total
population,
but 25% of the world's prison population,
largely due to the harsh punishments and mandatory minimums.
Minorities suffer because of this,
especially African Americans make up 40% of all US president inmates,
and while white kids are more likely to abuse drugs,
blankets aren't 10 times more likely to get arrested for drug offences.
Okay,
but is there actually something different we could do?
Is there a way out of this mass?
In the 1980s Switzerland experienced a public health crisis related to heroin
use.
HIV rates skyrocket is and street crime became a problem.
The Swiss authorities tried a new strategy,
harm reduction.
They opened free heroin,
made an incentive where addicts will be treated and stabilized.
There people would be given free heroin of high quality.
They would get clean needles and have access to safe injection rooms,
showers,
beds,
and medical supervision.
Social workers help them find housing and deal with other problems in their
lives.
The results were a sharp drop in drug related crime and two thirds of the people
in the centers got regular jobs because now they could focus on getting better
instead of financing their addiction.
Today,
over 70% of all heroin addicts in Switzerland received treatment.
HIV infections have dropped drastically.
Deaths from heroin overdoses have dropped by 50% and drug related street sex
work and crime has been reduced enormously.
So there are methods that are not only way cheaper,
but also actually work.
Instead of creating more problems.
Drug prohibition led to a system that bulldoze his human rights,
costs vast sums of money,
and creates a lot of human misery build in pursuit of an unobtainable goal.
After 40 years of fighting,
it's time to find the end,
the war on drugs and to move on to something better.
This video was supported by the open society foundations and by viewer donations
on Patriana.
If you want to learn more about how you can influence drug policy,
check out the stop the harm campaign.
We finally have some motion dice.
If you want your own quotes,
cause out poster tee shirts,
Mughal stickers of little monsters,
you can get them now at the DFT.
Be a stall.